we're here with one of my favorite
actors adam scott and he's also a film
buff who stars in the new apple tv plus
show
severance
so
we're gonna test your knowledge of best
pictures from oscars winners of the past
and if adam can guess four correct we're
throwing an oscars pizza party for
everyone in our audience that's right
everyone's gonna get
a gift
card for
not one not two not three not four not
five but six
deep dish pizzas from chicago's very own
the wonderful lou malnati's which is
like
famous so good delicious
so
so press is on if i don't get them right
then we
they don't get a pizza party is that
what's happening i don't know adam the
pizzas are in your hands are you ready
okay yes i am okay first up it's a movie
from the 1970s
see if you know what it is
uh-huh oh godfather yeah yeah 100
100.
[Applause]
all right we're going to the 80s
and the next poster pieces
jerry it's on fire
yes
show me the nineties
horoscope
[Applause]
all right i can taste the pizza i can
smell the pizza it's getting close
i see cheese oozing okay moving on to
this century
oh uh slumdog millionaire
yes
yes yes
yes is that it you did it that's four
right everybody gets the pizza party
[Applause]
to enjoy the oscars
and i say
have some slices and watch some
severance which is streaming now on
apple tv plus and new episodes are
dropping every friday it's fantastic i
can't wait for everybody to see it and
um adam scott i'm so thrilled to finally
make your acquaintance and my very best
to you and your whole family including
your frankie
yes and to you to your frankie as well
thank you i'm so thrilled to to be on
your show and to meet you thanks so much
oh thank you adam scott
[Music]